you made headlines and then it went
viral when you decided to pick Howard
University as the school of your choice
how did you decide that you were going
to Howard they were really broke the
four-way tie was no the things are going
on right now today you can see the
social unrest and the black lives matter
movement so by me taking this route to
HBCU and Howard University would
definitely bring awareness to all races
of what our people have contributed to
society in general you know we've done a
lot so when I first talked to mr. HBCU
it's not just like athletes or
entertainment that you see it's you know
politician lawyers doctors scientists
you know the list goes on and on the
first black Supreme Court justice that
you know how we need a person they're
good Marshall you know so when somebody
commits and does taste as well it's not
a shock in this movement right now in
terms of you deciding this is where I'm
gonna go
what are you saying to everyone just be
aware you know my way of leading
definitely bringing awareness and
educating people you know what's going
on today
once you everybody gets to realize and
um what you know back some dent in
society just it changes everything
that's not hope to inspire you know if I
can if I can go in there I can hold
myself you know be professional and I
know the whole world is watching me and
see how that's what this goes I know you
know despite a lot of people yeah
there's a rich legacy at HBCUs thank you
for highlighting you by making the
choice by going there we are so
appreciative to have you on the show
thank you so much I wish you nothing but
the best at Howard University thank you